і про сім'ю повстання харчування я кріс
тусується п'яту годину на перевірку висловить
і я ненавиджу джастін ви добрий знає
тому що ви зараз більше помічено кому
фанери не фаріон
колими приймали закон про вищий колір і
зараз у нас були дискусії, бо я
норма владно con центру та
і читку дізнатися кроки колою можна
засовувати і мову меншим звик джині
при початковому процесі в його світі
відьому вигляд закону
модну проекти ви здається що виконав
їдемо на прийнятий я телкам солідарна з
вами олексій закон сьогодні є
червоним з вузу ви цю норму до
конкретизації курки можна ви просто ось
і не за божа ним з дуба watching all і
собі дозволяє деки виклада че з брат і
заявляє студенту
і потім читати російську нові що й
коти виручку неприємно а ми з вузли
кількох до
заїду блювання photos на норми закону
понад свиту зварилися дзвонити або у
вас абсолютно слову у слову
таки нам я ще виключать цю норму збиті
жерці ми
і йому сам виключать із закону промишляла
світу все переключається на норму
джин на високо напруга ви
а так ми за вузли цілі проростання дуже
читку там ще в принципі можна одразу не
ти швед шоу людей буде працювати
вруном овна сміття це ваще під центрово
її грому диваном вусаги окей спасибі
дуги ти профі сильну лексику you олег
не може тут лего ти зміг би
національні машини в початковій
процес на вигляд міну і тут все дуже
музику на про можуть Туреччина я поважаються з
допуском серцю
форма його на нас сьогодні через
подвижнику
вид тотального викладання мови ми
менше